[موسيقى]
هذا كلام منطقي على العربيات وانا راويه
العالمي
القصه بدات هكذا في مدرسيه
باللغه العربيه وعم بحاول اني اشدها للدرس
بالحسنى في بعض الاحيان بالغضب والصراخ في
احيان اخرى طبعا للاسف بدون اي جدوى بدات
بالقاء خطبه عصماء للطفله اللي بدل ملل
وعدم الاهتمام واضحين على محياها وهي بتهز
براسها المدعيه التركيز والموافقه يمكن
مجامله الي او خوفا مني لا اكثر المهم
الخطبه كانت عن وجوب الاهتمام باللغه
العربيه وتعلم اصولها
وبانوعار علينا احنا كعرب انه ما نتكلم
لغتنا الام ورحت طبعا اتغنى بجمال اللغه
وفصاحتها وانه من المهم جدا في هذا الزمن
انه نكون متزوجين اللغه او ثنائين لغه
طبعا ليلا انتظرتني بالصبر حتى
المحاضره وبعدين نظرت اليه بكل براءه
وسالتني
ماما ليه ما بيتكلم جميع سكان الارض لغه
واحده طب ما كنا هيك راح نوفر كم هائل من
الوقت والجهد بنصرف عاده من عمرنا في تعلم
اللغات يعني باختصار لولا العيب كان بدها
تقول لي خلاص ما احنا كلنا بنحكي انجليزي
كلنا بنفهم على بعض وبالعربي بلا وجع قلب
يعني
بصراحه بعد كل الجهد والتوتر اللي تدريس
الاطفال بسببه عند اي ام واب ليلى اضحكتني
بتفكيرها العملي البريء والكسول في ذات
الوقت ولكن في نفس الوقت اخافتني ايضا على
مستقبل لغتنا العربيه واللغات الحيه بشكل
عام في زمن العولمه
طبعا اتبعت خطبه السابقه بخطبه اخرى ايضا
عصماء عن انه تعدد اللغات بيغني الثقافات
وانه البشر نشاوا في مناطق مختلفه بعد ما
هاجروا من قاره افريقيا وبالتالي كل منهم
كان له طريقته الخاصه في التواصل
حتى شعرت اني بصراحه فقدتها تماما يعني
كان ممكن احكي صيني كثير
المهم
ولكن هذا السؤال بقيه معي حتى قررت انه
احاول الاجابه عليه على سؤال ليلى تحديدا
في حلقه هذا الاسبوع اذا لماذا لا توجد
لغه واحده يتكلمها جميع سكان الارض
قبل البحث في اسباب ذلك حاولت اني ارجع
خطوه للوراء ورحت ابحث بدايه عن ما هي
اللغه اصلا وليش بنحتاجها وشو هي وظائفها
فهل هي وسيله تواصل ليس الا
معجم اللغه العربيه بعرف اللغه بانها صوت
الانسان المعبر عنه بالكلام بينما تعرفها
الصفحه الرسميه لعام اللغات الاصليه واللي
حددته الامم المتحده في عام 2019 والهدف
منه كان هو التوعيه بالتهديد المحدق
باللغات الاصليه حول العالم وبمخاطر
انقراضها بتعرفها بانها وسيله تواصل وسيله
لتحديد الهويه
وسيله للتعبير عن الثقافه والتاريخ وايضا
وسيله للتعلم اولاد الدفاع عن حقوقنا
الانسانيه وايضا وسيله
للانخراط في شتى المجالات الاجتماعيه
بتضيف الصفحه بانها يعني اللغه هي وسيله
حمايه ودفاع عن التقاليد والمعتقدات وسيله
ايضا لحمايه المجتمع عن طريق القانون
واحلال السلام اما المؤرخ يفعلنا وهراري
صاحب الكتاب الشهير سيفينس فبيقول انه قد
تكون اللغه هي اهم انجاز على الاطلاق
لانها امنت التواصل وهذا سهل التعاون
وبدون هذين العاملين لما استطاع البشر
اصلا انشاء حضارات ولما استطاعت هذه
الحضارات لازدهار والاستمرار
هل هذا بيعني انه كل البشريه نطقت بلغه
واحده في فتره من الفترات وهذه اللغه هي
اصل اللغات جميعا ام انه كان هناك لغات
متعدده منذ البدايه الحقيقه لا يوجد اجابه
قاطعه على هذا السؤال هناك مدارس فكر
بترجح انه تعدد اللغات هو الاصل بينما في
مدارس اخرى بتشوف انه من المنطقي اكثر انه
نفترض انه اجدادنا تكلموا جميعا نفس اللغه
قبل الهجره المتعدده خارج القاره
الافريقيه واذا كانت هذه الفرضيه صح
فالسؤال هنا هو مع مرور الوقت وتاثير
العولمه هل راح نرجع لنتكلم جميعنا لغه
واحده
شو رايكم
سؤال اخر بيطرح نفسهن وهو ما هو موقع
اللغه في التاريخ اصلا
للاجابه على هذا السؤال بحب ارحب بضيفي في
الرياض طارق القرني بحث في المناهج
النقديه
والتداريات اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ طارق معنا
في كلام منطقي
جميعا
الحقيقه انا كنت سالت سؤال في معرض يعني
بحثي وحديثي عن موضوع اللغه وهو شو هو
موقع بدايه شو هو الموقع اللغه في التاريخ
الحقيقه ان هذا السؤال سيعود بنا الى
تاريخ القديم قديما ولابد من هنا من
الاستعانه بكثير من الدراسات سواء كانت
الدراسات في علم اللغه التطوري او
التطوريه بشكل عام او
بعض الحفريات القديمه
اللغه والذي يهمنا هنا هو اللغه المتداول
الناس لان اذا اخذنا
امتداد اللغه القديم في سنعود الى كثير من
الدراسات التي تشير الى اكثر من مليون عام
لكن لعل اللغه الحقيقيه بدات عند الانسان
في الفتره ما بين 30.70000 سنه وهي لغه
التطويع التي بداها الانسان في تلك الفتره
الانسان اصبح مغايره لغيره من المخلوقات
نقولوا تحتنا الحيوانات طبعا باعتباره
قادره على تطويع له يعني تجدين مثلا عند
بعض الحيوانات او عند الحيوانات بشكل عام
ان الامر يكون واحد اما الانسان لا يستطيع
ان يعطي قصه كامله من اجل ان يخبر الاخر
[موسيقى]
يعني هو الحقيقه
هي فكره قدره الانسان على الحكايه ولا
يقولون ان الانسان
حكاهم في طبعه
وان هذا الامر اصبح التكيفيه انسان ولا
يمكن ان يتعلم اللغه او يطورها الى من
خلال الحكايه لكن المعضله هنا في في فكره
اللغه ان كل قصص الانسان منذ ذلك الوقت
الى الان هي كلها تعود الى مجموعه بسيطه
بعضهم 25 قصه يعني اي قصه قتل هي في
عصرتها تعود الى قابيل وهابيل اي قصه
طغيان تعود الى فرعون اي قصه اشكاليات او
مشاكل اسريه تعود الى يوسف لان هذه داخله
في المخ في المعهود الذهني البشري هي لها
طابعها الديني
ولكن بعد ذلك اصبحت وكانها ثابته في نظام
البشر
فهذه بدايات تكون اللغه ثم بعد ذلك طبعا
انتشرت اللغه عن طريق يعني لعلنت الحلقه
ايضا سنشير لها لكن هذه بدايه والاولى منذ
ذلك التاريخ وعلى هذا الشاره علوم كثيره
التطوريه او حتى تجدين هذا في علم اللغه
العصر التطوريات وغيرها من هذه العلوم
التي اهتمت بهادتك
طبعا هو يعني الموضوع عباره عن بحر من
المعلومات لو بدنا نبحث عن اصول كل اللغات
انا طبعا بهمني اعرف اصل لغتنا العربيه
وكيف تطورت راح ارجع لهاي النقطه في وقت
لاحق معلش اسمح لي ابقى معي استاذ طارق
راح اكمل سرد هذه القصه بلغه جميله ان شاء
الله تعجب المتابعين همم الحديث
اذا اللغه حاضره في جوهر كل مناحي حياتنا
وهي العمود الفقري ونواه الحضارات فعود
الى سؤال الاصلي لماذا لا نتكلم جميع نفس
اللغه اجابه هذا السؤال الحقيقي تكون في
عمق تاريخ الجنس البشري وعمق تطوره ايضا
في يومنا الحالي هناك زهاء سبات الاف لغه
حيه في العالم والحقيقه انه لا جواب قاطع
يفسر هذا العدد الكبير لكن هناك العديد من
النظريات اللي بتركز على انه التنوع
اللغابي جاء كردت فعل لعده عوامل واحداث
تاريخيه غيرت مصير جماعات بشريه عبر
التاريخ
اعزائي قبل ما نفصل هذه العوامل بحب اعود
الى ضيفي الاستاذ طارق القرني لحتى نتحدث
عن كيف بنقدر نفرق ما بين اللغه واللهجه
يعني في الان في العالم اكثر من 7000
وتحديدا 768 لغه حيه ما زال الناس ناطقين
فيها عم نحكي هون عن لغات منفصله تماما ام
انه في بعض منها عباره عن لهجات مختلفه
نفس اللغه
هي صوت صوت الكون بشكل عام
اللغه اللغه العربيه بعرفها انه صوت
الانسان للتعبير عن حاجاته
لان
هذا المعجم خاص بمفهوم من العرب او
بمفاهيم معجميه الصرفه لكن المعنى الحقيقي
لابعد من ذلك الذي تجدينه يعني من عند من
اهتم بالمعنى
وسناتي لماذا هذا التعريف مخلل يعني الذي
ذكر في المعاجم
اذا اللغه هنا تنصرف الى لغه الكون بشكل
عام دائما ما اضرب مثال ان المطر اذا نزل
فكانه يحكي لك ويقول ابتعد حتى لا تغرق
هذه لغه
لا يخاطبك بلسان ويخاطبك
بعلاميه معينه اصبحت معهوده عند الانسان
اللسان هنا هو الذي يعني نقول عنه عربيه
انجليزيه فرنسيه وغير ذلك اي انسان مجتمع
معين
عندما جاءت
المعاجم العربيه وقالت ان اللغه لانهم
كانوا يرون ان اللغه العربيه
تحديدا في ذلك الوقت كانت هي لغه العالم
الذي يعرفونه يعرفون غيره
[موسيقى]
فكانت هذه الفكره لهذا تجدين حتى ان
استاذنا الجاحظ ما كان يعني كان ينظف
كثيرا على ان اللغه العربيه لا يمكن ان
تنكره
بالتحديدا الشعر العربي الذي هو ركن اللغه
العربيه لا يمكن ابدا يترجم لابد من تعلم
اللغه فاذا هذه الفكره هي فكره هي فكره
القوي او طريقه القوي في تصدير هذه
المفاهيم حتى تتناسب مع معه ذاته لكن اذا
اخذناها بطريقه محايده بعيده يعني عن فكره
ان كل امه او كل اصحاب لغه من الممكن ان
يوظف بلغتهم حتى تصبح هي السائده كما يسوق
الان مثل اللغه الانجليزيه مثلا او يحاول
الصينيون ان يفعل ذلك بلغتهم اذا اخذنا في
طريقه
للعلوم
اللغه هنا كما قلت انها تتجه الى او ابعد
من ذلك يعني حتى علامات الجسد مثلا الذي
لا تصدق هذا الذي يسميها جمل مفيده او
كلمات لها على سبب المثال الغمزه لها معنى
عندما اسلم على احد مثلا من بعيد لها معنى
وانا
اللسان لا هو معقود بهذا اللسان الذي لابد
ان هتسبك معي وهنا تاتي حتى بعض الافكار
التي تدخل فعلى سبيل المثال الجنود
الجنون الذي يمكن ان يلطف ويقال الابداع
هو عباره عن لغه ايضا عباره عن اللسان
لكنه جمله غير مفيده يعني الذي يتحدث
يتحدث بلساننا بنفس الكلمات لكن عنده خلل
في موضوع الاختيار والتركيب فيختار من
الكلمات ثم يركبها بطريقه غير صحيحه وهي
الطريقه التي لا نحددها ونجد هذا ايضا عند
المبتدئ في تعلم اللغه اللغه مثلا نجد انه
مثلا يغير في الكلمات والترتيب حتى يظهر
وكانه لغته » فتصبح احيانا يعني مصدرا
للسخريه
او حتى للشقق احيانا طبعا هذا سيزيد ايضا
في حالات نفسيه
هذا كله من المعاني الداخله في التفريق
بين اللغه واللسان وما هي فيها
الان
ناتي للهجات
عندما تتوسع الجغرافيا
ويصبح التداول الاجتماعي للغه
وايضا الجنوح او الخروج من القريه الى
المدينه يعني بدايه تشكل الحضاره المدنيه
لنقل الانزال الذي كان موجود
[موسيقى]
ومعارفه محدوده
والتصور بالحياه محدود انما في المدينه
اختلط هؤلاء كلهم
ببعض
فخرجت كلمات جديده وتراكيب جديده وتهيئه
جديده
ان اللغه هي عباره عن مكافات وظيفيه فقط
يعني ما هي هذه اللغه هي مكافات وظيفيه
انا الان اتحدث معك
حديث هذا اذا لم يكافئ شيئا موجود في
ذاكرتك فلن تفهمي معقول فانت كل ما تعمليه
الان هو ان تكافئ كلامي
اشرح وضح واشتقصد ما فهمت عليك او ان
احيانا سوء الفهم قد يصل الى مراحل متقدمه
قد يصل الى القضاء ايضا حتى يحكم بيننا
هذه كلها ان اللغه لا يمكن ان نصل الى
معرفه الجوهريه ان ما نصل الى تقريبا
طب هل هو الذي سيجعل اللغه متوسعه
واستحاله ان يتحدث الناس بحديث واحد بما
او بلغه واحده لماذا لانها هي مكافات
تعتمد على الصوره انت الان عندما مثلا
ترين منظر معينه
فانت مثلا ستقولي كذا يعني هنا يضرب مثال
في ال في في
اللغه او في كتب اللغه يقولون مثلا لو قلت
لمن لطفل مثلا في القريه همم ما اسمها هذه
سيقول دجاج يقول ما هي الدجاجه سيقول لك
طائر ولكنه لا يطير وعنده سائقين لكنه لا
ينبغي
هذه اوصاف ولانه اوصاف قريبه من البيئه
الزراعيه التي يعيش فيها مثلا عندما نقول
مثلا لطفل على سبيل المثال في المدينه ما
هذه سيقول هذه التي ناكلها في وجبه كذا
مثلا
سناتي الى اخر والذي للتو بدا يتعلم مثلا
في كتب هذه التي لونتها في الكتاب مثلا
[موسيقى]
ياخذ العالم الخارجي ويكافئه بما يعرفه
وهذا ما يجعل في احيان كثيره يتحول
او تتحول اللغه من هي سلوك ماده من الحديث
الذي اقوله هذا الصوت
هذا السلوك احيانا لا استطيع ان اخرج ما
بداخلي من خلاله فانتجي الى السلوك مادي
اخر وهو البكاء والصراخ
وهذه من الحيل التي تعلمها الانسان لغويا
منذ الطفوله من الطفل
لان اخذ كذا وكذا مثلا
الى الصراخ والبكاء لانه ما اخذ مثلا
مطلوبه فكانه هنا يصدر لغه
الامهات والامهات اقرب للاطفال من الاباء
ستجدين من الامهات يفهمون ان هذه السرقه
هل هي صحيحه ام انها حيله
هم اكثر الناس درايه الان يعلمون بهذا حتى
بنوع من الغريزه او نوع من ال ال اللغه
النفسيه المشتركه
فهذه الفكره مهمه ايضا
الى كيف يتعلم اصلا طفل مثلا
لكتابتها كان بسبب يعني
بنتي اللي همم كثير يعني مستصعبه بتعلم
اللغه العربيه بصراحه وانا بعاني معها في
هذا الموضوع وسالتني سؤالك كبير انه ليه
ما كنا بنحكي نفس اللغه وانا بالحقيقه
عملت الحلقه هاي علشان احاول اجيب الاجابه
على هذا السؤال
العوامل اللي بتشجع على ظهور لغه جديده
بدايه
العامل الاساسي هو المكان والزمان
اجدادنا البشر الاوائل كانوا بيتنقلوا من
منطقه لاخرى بحثا عن الموارد وفرص افضل
للعيش واللغه بتتغير وبتطور حتى تصبح لغه
اخرى مختلفه بعض الشيء ولكن مشتقه عن
اللغه الاصليه
اللي هي مثل الفرنسيه والاسبانيه واللغات
الساميه طبعا معروفه بالعربيه والعبريه
لها جذر واحد واصل واحد فتخيلوا المشهد
مجموعات من البشر اللي بيتكلموا نفس اللغه
تتفرق وبتهاجر لمناطق مختلفه مع مرور
الوقت تطور لهجاتهم بطريقه مختلفه عن بعض
وبعد مرور الوقت الكافي تصبح هاي لهجه
نوعا ما لغه جديده
العمل الاخر هو الحرب
فدافع الهجره ما كان دائما سلمي او في وقت
الصلب فبعض الحروب ادت لظهور لغات جديده
وانقراض ايضا لغات كانت موجوده الحرب ممكن
تدفع بمجموعه من البشر للهجره وبالتالي
بتكرر السيناريو الي ذكرنا قبل قليل او قد
تؤدي بعض الحروب الانقراض لغه كامله عن
طريق الاباده الجماعيه لسكان الاصليين
الناطقين بلغتهم الخاصه او ممكن تجبر قوه
مستعمره الشعب المستعمر على تركته وتبني
لغتها وهذا بالفعل اللي حصل للسكان
الاصليين في القاره الامريكيه او حتى في
استراليا وهذا ما فعله الاستعمار الفرنسي
بالجزائر ولولا رحمه الله وصمود
الجزائريين وتمسكهم بلغتهم وثقافتهم يمكن
ما بقي من ينطق بالعربيه في الجزائر اليوم
الجغرافيا عام الاخر هذا العمل ممكن ما
يفسر سبب جود هذا الكم الكبير من اللغات
ولكنه بيعطي تعليل لسبب عدم وجود تكافؤ في
توزيع هذا الكم او هذا العدد من اللغات
على بقاع الارض المختلفه
فتخيلوا ان هناك
225 لغه اصليه في اوروبا اللي عدد سكانها
774 مليون بينما في بلد صغير قريب من
استراليا اسمها بابو نيوجيني او
غينيا الجديده اللي ما بيتجاوز عدد سكانها
9 ملايين نسمات لديها على الاقل 820 لغه
اصليه والسبب جغرافيتها الصعبه
الجغرافيتها مليانه بجبال وغابات وانهار
ومستنقعات وكل هذه الصعوبه او الجغرافيا
الصعبه كانت تبقي سكانها معزولين عن بعضهم
البعض بيعيشوا من قبائل صغيره العدد
وهذه العزله وقت طويل تؤدي
منطقيا لظهور لغات مختلفه لكنها تبقى لغات
قبليه
عامل اخر تخيلوا هو المطر قام باحثون من
المركز الاصطناعي التطوري الوطني في
استراليا باستخدام التكنولوجيا الحديثه
لحتى يحددوا العوامل اللي بتاثر في تنوع
اللغات الاصليه في استراليا وخلصوا الى
انه انماط وطول المطر في استراليا اثرت
بشكل مباشر على عدد وتوزيع اللغات الاصليه
في هذا البلد
مباشره باللغه لكن من المنطقه انه يؤثر
المطر على قدره اي منطقه على تامين
الموارد للبشر فالمناطق الممطره تتحلى
بيوفره في الموارد من طعامه من شرابه
بالتالي بتكون بؤر تجمع لمجموعات كبيره من
الناس وهذا باثر على عدد اللغات اللي قد
تنشا في هذه المنطقه
عامل اخر اسمه التكيف الصوتي اللي هو
اكوستك اداب تيشن ايضا مهم هو لا يفسر سبب
وجود لغات متعدده فحسب بل كمان بعلل ليش
كل هذه اللغات بتبدو مختلفه تماما من
الناحيه الصوتيه التكيف الصوتي بيتعلق
بطريقه تغيير الحيوانات للاصوات اللي
بيصدروها بحسب طبيعه البيئه اللي بيعيشوا
فيها حتى يكونوا مسموعين مثلا في المناطق
اللي بتنتشر فيها الغابات الكثيفه وبتكون
حاره احرف العله تسمع بشكل اسهل بكثير من
الحروف الساكنه وهيك اللغات اللي بتنشا في
هذه المناطق بتكون غنيه باحرف العله اكثر
من الاحرف الساكنه
هل هناك اصول مشتركه لكل اللغات الارض
يعني منلاحظ في شغلات متشابهه حتى بلغات
لا تمت بصله لبعضها البعض يعني مثلا كل
اللغات الساميه ممكن يكون فيه كلمات
مشابهه او جذورها لها جذور مشتركه
اللغات الرومانسيه اللي انبثقت عن اللغه
اللاتينيه مثل الفرنسيه الاسبانيه
كل فيها برده كلمات مشتركه ولكن لما بفكر
مثلا بكلمه طاوله وما تعني
والحرف الاول اللي فيها طاء وافكر في كلمه
تيبو بالانجليزي وهي تعني نفس الشيء وبرده
اول حرف منها كثير
كلمه كوب
كاب
هل هناك يعني هل هذا الشيء جاء من الطلاق
في الحضاري
وتبادل الثقافات عبر السنين ولا في اصول
وجذور مشتركه نتيجه لانه عقل الانسان بفكر
بنفس الطريقه
نوعا ما بعبر بنفس الطريقه ايضا
في مسائل المقارنات باللغه
المهم هنا ان ناخذ كيف اصلا بدا الانشقاق
اللغوي
سناخذ ايضا بحديث العلمي التطور القديم
وين البشر كانوا في شرق افريقيا ثم
انتقلوا الى الجزيره
الى اوزباكستان في هذه الجغرافيا تحديدا
بدا الانسان يتطور شيئا فشيئا عبر سنوات
طويله نحن نتحدث عن الاف السنوات
الى اندونيسيا والى الغربيه
ولهذا يقال انه اذكياء المجموعه
فمثلا الانسان الذكي بمعنى
بلغه ايضا يعني يعني لن اقول نعيدها الى
قاعده وهي قاعده البقاء للاصلح
هنا هذه الفكره فكره من الذي يستطيع ان
يتحدث ويجعل غيره يتاثر به وهنا سنجد ان
القوي في اعلامه للغته او في اعلامه لرواه
وتصوراته هو الذي يجذب الاخرين
وستجدين هذا واضح جدا في كثير يعني لنفترض
ان مثلا الان لو اخذنا اللغه الانجليزيه
لماذا هي بهذا الحضور
لان قوه
الاعلام
ولكن الاعلام الامريكي ليس الاعلام بمعنى
التلفزيون
همم لا لا ليس فقط بالمعنى المعروف لكلمه
اعلام انما كيف السوق للغه عن طريق مثلا
العلم عن طريق النظريات عن طريق
الاقتراحات نعم عن طريق القوه الناعمه ان
اجعلك ترى
انك لابد ان تنجذب الي بكل الطرق هذه كلها
جزء الى ماذا الى التصورات فتصبح تفكر
بنفسك
نفس الفكره في الحضاره العربيه عندما جذبت
غيرها من الفرس والروم وغيره من الحضارات
التي قريبه منها فاصبحوا يفكرون بالعقل
العربي حتى انا امام النحو سيبويه هو اصله
فارسي ما هذا لاحظي كيف جذب الى العربيه
واصبح امامكم يعني العالم كثيره اذا
الفكره هنا هي تاخذ ذكر اجتماعيه وكيف
تتطور هذه المجتمعات عن طريق تكييف تصورات
الذهنيه
ومطابقتها للواقع الاجتماعي
فاذا الفكره الان قديمه جدا
وانتشار الانسان هو الذي جعله غير قادر
على ان يتحدث بلغه واحده لكن يبقى هنا
مساله الترابط الحضاري كما قلت قبل قليل
بين المجتمعات تقرب كثير من الكلمات
والمصطلحات
همم عادي حتى تصبح وكانها جزء
اصيل في اللغه
العربيه سجدين هذا حتى في النصوص الدقيقه
جدا او التي لها يعني مستعل المستويات في
اللغه القران مثلا كلمه سندس مثلا
اللغه او اللغات بشكل عام وبدات راح اتحدث
طبعا بعد قليل ايضا عن موضوع همم انقراض
اللغه او موتها قبل هيك شو اصل اللغه
العربيه هل كان هناك لانه يقال لانه
بالجزيره العربيه حتى قبل الاسلام كان
هناك قبائل كثيره عربيه ولكن كلها لديها
السنه مختلفه يعني هل هذه كانت فقط لهاجات
مختلفه للغه العربيه ام انه همم يعني
همم كانت لغات مختلفه كلها ربما يعني جاي
من نفس الشجره ووو وتنتمي لنفس عائله
اللغات الساميه ولكن هل شو شو اصل اللغه
العربيه وكيف توحدت طبعا بالاسلام له دور
كبير والقران الكريم له دور كبير كيف
توحدت لتصبح هذه اللغه العربيه الفصحى
اللي احنا بنعرفها اليوم
بالنسبه للغه العربيه في الحديث عن اصلها
يطول جدا لان الخلاف فيها كبير
لكن يهمني هنا لان كانت شفويه قبل الاسلام
فلم تكون مكتوبه وهل اصل اللغه العربيه
طبعا هو سامي لكن اللغه العربيه هل هو
بائت مع اللغات البائده هل دون احد باللغه
العربيه
هل الجميع هذه اللهجات السعودي
هل هي كانت فقط في الجزيره العربيه الخلاف
فيها طويل لكن يهمني كما قلت مساله ان
العرب
واللغه التي يعني نتحدث بها الان اللغه
الفصيحه
هي جاءت تقريبا كما يشير الى ذلك الجاحظ
غيره
انها قبل الاسلام ب 150 الى 200 سنه فقط
في هذا الحدود
حتى انه هو نفسه الجاحظ وكثير منه يعني
ارجعها الى الى عدي من الى الى ما يسمى
اعلاميين الزير سالم
لانه اول من هذا الشعر واول من وصل الينا
شاب طبعا هذه الفكره الان اذا اخذناها من
ناحيه ما وصل اليه والا العرب فيهم عرب
بائده التعادل وجديس
لكن الفكره هنا المهمه هو هذه اللغه التي
ينقسمت الى ما يسمى امرين
اللغه الفصيحه للتفكير وليست التواصل
واللغه العاميه للتواصل وليست التفكير
الفرق بينهما مهندسا
اللغه العليا
انما انما اذا اخذناها باللهجات الدول
مثلا لا تفكر باللهجات او بطريقه اللهجات
لانه فكرت بطريقه اللهجات فنحن ناخذ
المعلومه لنقل من من ليس اهلا للعلم او
اهلا بان يتصدق الناس بعمومهم احاديثهم في
التواصل هي احاديث في حالات ولهذا الانسان
الحكيم هو الذي يعني لا يعطي مجالا لغيره
بان يعني يستمر نفسه احاديث الناس في
عمومها كلها عباره عن انفعالات نفسيه
لكن الاحاديث التي تخرج باللغه الفصيحه ثم
بعد ذلك تجمع عرق كامل من الخليج العربي
الى المحيط هذه كلها لا يمكن ان تكون الا
باللغه الفصيحه لماذا لانها مقعده
ومفصله ونستطيع من خلال هذه الكلمات التي
نقولها ان نعود الى حصولها منذ مئات
السنوات
وهذا يجعلنا نفكر بطريقه منطقيا تابعه
لمنطق اللغه نفسه اما الاحاديث العاديه
هذه فهي للتواصل فقط التواصل البشري طبعا
هذه الفكره فكره هذه اللغه
هذه تقريبا
انتهت الى ان اللغه
للتفكير في عمومها يعني نتحدث في اللغه ما
نسميها نحن الفصيح للتفكير لان لها ارتباط
مباشر ادراك هذه بدات تاسيس هذه الفكره ما
عاد شو المشكله
عند العرب قديما ولكن نتحدث عن مدارس
حديثه تمت بهذا الامر
لكن ماتوا موسكي اصبحت حقيقه ان اللغه
للتفكير وليست فقط للتواصل التواصل هنا
يتجه للهجات كما قلت يعني مثلا لو افترضنا
مثلا في السعوديه مثلا ستجدين ان من هو في
منطقه عسير
ان القبائل فقط في منطقه عسير ليست متحده
في طريقتها في الحديث ولا في طريقتها في
التاخر
او في التعبير وهي منطقه واحده فكيف مثلا
في شمال المملكه ثم شهاده على كل الدول
لو اخذتي مثلا شقيقين
ستجدين عند التامل ان طريقه هذا
الانفعاليه
غير طريقه هذا الانفعاليه لكن لو كتب هذا
وهذا باللغه الفصيحه
طبعا رغم هذا الغنى اللغوي
كبيره بتحدق بهذا التنوع فبحسب المنشور
السنوي اثناء لذيذ واللي بيوثق وبيوفر
احصائيات ومعلومات اخرى عن اللغات الحيه
حول العالم
34% من اللغات العالم الموثقه وعددها
بالضبط 797 لغه هي مهدده بالانقراض بينما
منظمه اليونسكو بتقول انه النصف لغات
العالم راح تختفي بحلول عام 2000 و100 هذا
يعني انه اكثر من 3000 لغه ستمسح من على
وجه الارض خلال 75 عام
الخبراء في هذا المجال بيقولوا انه بلد
مثل اسبانيا فيها على الاقل ست لغات معرضه
للانقراض كنتيجه للاحتلال الثقافي منظمه
فاونديشن فور
لتوثيق لحمايه اللغه المهدده بتقول انه في
الوقت اللي لغات مثل الانجليزيه
والاسبانيه الصينيه اصبحوا اكثر قيمه
واكثر اهميه فانه لغات قبليه كثيره راح
تندثر ففي اوروبا اللي لديها اكثر من 250
لغه اصليه
52 من هاي اللغات رح تحتضر فعلا بينما 50
اخرين من هذه اللغات المهدده بالفعل
بالموت في ذات الوقت بتقول مصادر صحفيه
هنديه انه الهند فقدت 20% من لغاتها منذ
عام 1961 لكن لماذا وكيف تموت اللغه
ببساطه بتموت اللغه لما بيتوقف الناطقين
بها عن استخدامها في حياتهم اليوميه لكن
الشعوب ما بيتوقفوا فجاه عن استخدام اي
لغه الموضوع اعقد من ذلك بكثير وله مسببات
كثيره السبب الاول هو الاستعمار معظم
اللغات المهدده بالانقراض هي لغات قبليه
بيتكلمها عدد صغير من البشر عاده بيكونوا
مستعمرين من قوه كبيره اجنبيه على الارجح
انتهاء النظام الاستعماري يمكن ان نقول
بانه جاء بالامس في مقياس عمر الشعوب وما
زال حاضر في ذاتنا بريطانيا فرنسا اسبانيا
والبرتغال كلها جعلت لغتها هي المهيمنه في
الامريكتين وفي اسيا بحيث انه في الدول
المستعمره التحدث باللغه المستعمر هي
ضروره لا التعامل الرسمي والاجتماعي
والنهوض الاقتصادي ومع الوقت والاجيال
للاسف بتندثر في اللغه الاصليه وعلمنا
العربي طبعا مش غريب على الاستعمار واسباب
صمود لغتنا العربيه جديده بالدراسه ولكن
في راي المتواضع النظام من الرئيس الى
استمرار اللغه العربيه هو بالفعل القران
الكريم
السبب الثاني هو الغزو والحرب واللي بيؤدي
الى وقت لغه وثقافه شعب كامل بين ليله
وضحاها بسبب التهجير والتطهير العرقي
وعلمنا ايضا مش غريبه على هيك فضائح وهذا
حصل فعلا عبر التاريخ من زمن الامبراطوريه
الرومانيه وصولا للاستعمار الغربي للشرق
والامريكتين واسيا وافريقيا واللي انتهى
في القرن الماضي فقط
سبب اخر هو الاحتباس الحراري والتغير
المناخي نعم
وممكن تسالوا شو علاقه هذاك الحقيقه انا
نفسي اتفاجئت من هاي العلاقه وانا عم بحضر
هاي الحلقه مع ما نشهد طبعا من تغيير في
المناخ لابد وان يبدا بالتاثير على بعض
اللغات خصوصا اللغات المحكيه في جزر
المحيط الهادئ مثال على ذلك جزيره تكون
صغيره في جنوب غرب المحيط الهادئ هي جزيره
صغيره ومعزوله واصبحت مهدده بالغرق بسبب
التغير المناخي وفي حال حصل ذلك وتم اعاده
توطين سكانها 400 عددهم 400 فقط في بابوني
يمكنني المجاوره راح تنصهر لغتهم تماما في
منطقه اللغات الموجوده في هذا البلد
ستختفي بشكل عام ضغوطات البيئيه بتؤدي الى
زياده التنقل للهجره
على اللغه وعلى انتشارها او انتشارها
سيكون كارثه مش فقط على الشعوب المعنيه
ولكنه كارثي ايضا على راس العلوم
الادراكيه والمعرفيه ايضا
نيجي الان للسبب الاكثر خطوره في رايي في
عالمنا المعاصر وهو العولمه والاستعمار
الثقافي من خلال القوه الناعمه وادوات
ومنتجات التقدم التكنولوجيا
العولمه والانترنت والتواصل المتواصل غير
كوكبنا للابد كل ذلك فتح من ناحيه ابواب
الحصول على التعليم ولكن في ذات الوقت فتح
الباب لمستويات اعلى من عدم التسامح فتح
ابواب المعرفه والتاخي العالمي وفي ذات
الوقت فتح الباب للارهاب والتعصب الوطني
من الطبيعي انه استعمل لغه واحده في
التواصل عبر العالم وهذا هو المنطق
المعاصر ويمكن هو اللي دفع بليله للسؤال
عن جد وتعلم لغات اخرى غير اللغه العالميه
المنتشره الان طبعا هذا جيل عملي بطريقه
مخيفه على فكره
اللغه الانجليزيه لعبه هذا الدور حتى الان
لكن على ما يبدو لغات اخرى رئيسيه بدات
تلعب دور اكبر في السنوات الاخيره على
مسرح التواصل العالمي مثل اللغه الاسبانيه
والروسيه والبرتغاليه وتخيلوا كمان اللغه
العربيه ايضا
لاخذه كلها لغات ينطق بها ملايين من البشر
وربما هذا هو معيار وضامن استمرار اي لغه
وبالتالي حتى اللغات اللي صحتها منيحه
نوعا ما ستصبح في مرمى الخطر بسبب العولمه
مثل لغه الكاتاللام في اسبانيا والباسك
اوسيتان في فرنسا ويمكن ما تصمد لعده عقود
قادمه اذا لم تدعمها الحكومات زي ما فعلت
ايرلندا
بحيث انه في ايرلندا اللغه الانجليزيه
ليست هي اللغه الرسميه في هذه الجمهوريه
ولكن هي اللغه الاصليه جيلك لكن يمكن
الموضوع موضوع ايرلندا متعلق اكثر بالهويه
الوطنيه ومقاومه الهيمنه البريطانيه في
شمال البلاد
يمكن ان يجيبن على هذه الحاله الافريقيه
بعد اللغات الافريقيه مثلا عام 2008
لكن الاستعمار اما ان يكون لقوه جاذبيه
الحضاره فما قلنا قبل قليل
العولمه
لم اجبرك عليه لكن قوتي كانها فاضت عليك
فاصبحت او فاصبحت انت وهن يعني في المجتمع
لا تقبلون الا بلغه كما كانت عند العرب مع
الفرس زعلتك تختار لغتي لتصبح لغتي
همم احسنت هذا اولا وهي لغه الدوله في ذلك
الوقت لان حتى الان يعني فارس والسند
وكلها كانت في دوله واحده يعني هي كانت
مناطق يعني ليست الدول واحده
لكن في الحاله الافريقيه لا الاستعمار كان
بقوه السلاح لو اخذنا مثلا
اللغه الاساسيه عندها ليست اللغه
الرومانسيه المعروف
التي البلد
الفرنسيه والانجليزيه يعني في همم يعني
تنازع كبير بينهما بعض مثلا لغه حتى
التدريس الفرنسيه
ما زالت باب الدول العربيه تفضل الكتابه
او البحث او باللغه الفرنسيه
الاعوام الاخيره اعتقد انه كان هناك صح
همم يعني اهميه التمسك باللغه وبالهويه
وبالثقافه وحتى همم يعني همم كثير من
الدول الغت همم اللغه الفرنسيه بالمغرب
العربي
مجموعه كبيره من همم في العرب بشكل عام اا
يعني تعتريهم يعني نوع من الاستعلاء عندما
في هذا الوقت لا اشكاله هو لا اشكالك ذلك
قد اجيد مثلا عشر لغات مثل عبد الرحمن
بدوي
لا يسمح اعتقد انك تكون احادي اللغه
في زمن العولمه
الشروط الاكاديميه وكذا يعني الانسان عادي
يعني لان اللي نقل هذا الانسان العادي
الذي ليس ملزومه بفروض معين مثلا
بالاكاديميه هذه الانسان العادي قد يعني
الفكره اللغه او قوه حضور اللغه الاخرى
مثلا
المهمه ان ان نربط دائما ما بين تحضر
الامه وقدرتها على ترجمه مثلا همم
العلوم الاخرى بشكل عام لان هذه الترجمه
تجعل ابناء هذا المجتمع يفكرون بلغتي
ممم ولهذا يعني مثلا في في زمن لا اعرف
حقيقه تنهلو ما زال الى الان لا يعني اظن
سوريا والاردن
لستم متاكده من الاردن كانوا يدرسون حتى
الطب العربيه
عند السوريين من اي ربما كان اخر لو نحكي
بالحموم يعني
حتى لو اخذت المسلسلات مثلا سوريه لاحظي
كيف ان مثلا بما اننا الذكر ما قبل قليل
مسلسل الزير سالم او حتى مثلا حتى اسماء
مثلا الفنانين عابد فهد او مثلا سلوم سلوم
حداد اصبحوا نجوم
وعرفوا عن طريق مسلسلات تاريخيه عربيه
المسلسل
فعلا فعلا في ما يتعلق بموت اللغات يعني
انا باشعر او هذا رايي يعني المتواضع ما
بعرف اذا بتتفق معي او لا انه ربما من
اكبر العوامل اللي اليوم بحياتنا المعاصره
بشكل خطر على اللغات المختلفه هي العولمه
وخصوصا انه احنا طبعا كل كل عصر همم كان
هناك لغه العالم في لما كانت مثلا روما
كانت اللغه اللاتينيه قبل ذلك كانت لغه
المثقفين ولغه الثقافه واللغه العليا كانت
اليونانيه اللغه العربيه كانت لغه العالم
لما كنا احنا في وضع قوه وكنا نحكم نص
العالم همم الانجليزي طبعا عن طريق همم
العولمه او قبل ذلك عن طريق الاستعمار
انتشر بشكل كبير احنا هلا مرحله حرجه لانه
مش عم بنحكي عن اللغه الانجليزيه
لانها لغه العالم الان وممكن انه تتغير
الظروف الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه
وتاتي لغه اخرى
لغه قوه
ثانيه همم سير هي المنتشره الان في عصر
التقدم التكنولوجي لغه التكنولوجيا هي
الانجليزيه هي اللغه الانجليزيه هل وطبعا
وفي عندك القوه الناعمه
وكماذا تفضلت حضرتك تسويق للغه الانجليزيه
اعلاميه بكل مناحي
بكفي هوليود وافلامها والسوشل ميديا وكل
هذا الكلام كله بالانجليزي حتى ان الاطفال
عمل لها حفظ مش بالضروره بدول يعني لا
تركز على همم اللغه الانجليزيه ولكن
هنعرفوا يحكوا انجليزي من غير ما يتعلموه
لانه حواليهم في كل مكان هل لازم نقلق على
لغاتنا وهون بتحدث كمان عن اللغه العربيه
بشكل خاص على مستقبلها في ظل هذه العولمه
واذا كنا بدنا نكون جزء من هذا العالم
لازم نحكي لغته
عاليه يعني هي اللغه الانجليزيه هل هناك
خطر على لغاتنا
لانه تبقى او تتحول اللغه العربيه مثلا
لغه متداوله فقط عند النخبه او لغه فقط
للنصوص الدينيه زي ما كانت اللغه العبريه
بفتره من الفترات وبعدين تم اعاده احياءها
نتيجه للظروف السياسيه انشاء دوله اسرائيل
وما ذلك فاعيد احيا هذه اللغه بين ما اعدت
قرون وهي لغه تستخدم فقط في النصوص
الدينيه
والممارسات ممارسات الطقوس الدينيه هل
لازم نقلق على لغتنا العربيه وعلى
مستقبلها
الخلق في اللغه العربيه انا لا ارى ان من
الصحيح لان غيرنا كذا وكذا
انما نحاول ان نؤسس حضارتنا الداخليه عن
طريق الاعتماد على الواقع العربي او اللغه
العربيه
لا يمكن ان تنمو اللغه الا اذا اصبح
المجتمع نامي معه يعني الوعي الجمعي لفضاء
العمومي التقدم الاجتماعي التواصل الحضاري
الاخلاقي كل هذا هو الذي ينمي اللغوي
يجعلها تدوم اما غير ذلك فهو الذي يميته
وهذا ما وهذا ما حصل هذا المعلومات
هذا ما حصل مثلا في رواندا مليون شخص
قتلوا في تلك الاشكلات التي نعم فاذا نحن
الان امام همم امام فكره مهمه جدا وهي ان
مكونات الحضاره التي منها اللغه
التي منها اللغه لابد ان تتكاتف كلها من
اجل ان تتعزز اللغه اللغه لا تعيش فقط
ونحن نردد
انها مثل لغه القران
قد يترجم القران
بالمجتمع الى ان يتحدث بلغه غير لغته مثلا
تحدثنا قبل قليل عن بعض الدول التي اصبحت
اللغه الرسميه
حتى لما لو تاخذ مثلا همم
يعتبر متقدمه مثلا زي جنوب افريقيا لا
يوجد لغتها الاصليه اذا الفكره هنا تعود
ايضا الى كثير من عوامل المجتمع لابد هنا
ان نهتم بالمجتمع اهتمامه بالمجتمع سيجعل
عندنا هذه ايضا الماء يعني انا في ظني ان
اي امه متطوره
ومتحضره هي التي لا يجبر فيها الفرد على
التعلم غير لغته يعني المفترض ان يكون
هناك
بعيد عن هذا الموضوع بس ما هو كمان في
متطلبات للعصر استاذ طارق
الموجودين مثلا في هذه الامه الى ان يتعلم
لغه غير اللغه الاخرى
المفترض ان يكون هناك مجموعه وعبر مؤسسات
معينه وهم من يتعلمون هذه اللغه
ويترجمونها عن طريق مراكز ومعاهد كثيره
على الانسان العادي وان نجعله سببا
لانقطاع الحضاره الانسانيه
يعني حتى في كثير من الدراسات التي تشير
الى الفرنسي او الالماني او الامريكي تشير
الى النسب لا تتجاوز الثماني في المئه
الذين يجدون لغه غير لغه الترجمه قويه
احنا بالعالم العربي بنحكي لغات اكثر مما
هم مش مضطرين بس احنا مضطرين
يعني انا المفترض لنفترض ان في الوطن
العربي هناك مثلا 100 مركز موثوق للترجمه
همم الكتاب الذي ينزل مثلا في نيويورك او
في باريس او في المانيا يترجم في ظرف
شهرين ثلاثه سنه انا في هذه الحاله لا
احتاج الى لغه اخرى يفترض ان اكون عندي
هذا الامن كان همم اصبح مثلا في وطن
العربي اصل الى مرحله انني لا احتاج الى
ان اهاجر شرق الارض وغربها حتى اعمل يعني
ان شاء الله انه نوصل مرحله من المراحل
طيب ولكن عشان قبل ما ننهي حبيتني عن جد
يعني زمان لم تجيبني بصراحه على السؤال هل
انت قلقان ولا لا خصوصا لما بتطلع على
واقع عالمنا العربي واحنا مش بحاله همم
خلينا نستغني عن لغات العالم ابدا
لو اخذتي مثلا اللغه العربيه وقلت وما زلت
عند رايي هذا الذي بثته كثيرا عام 19
والان 2022
كم عدد الذين كانوا يتحدثون العربيه
الفصيحه والتي يتحدثونها الان
اسباب
سيكون شهر لكن الفكره في النتيجه كم عدد
الان حتى لو اخذنا المسلسلات التي تحدثنا
عنها وهي فنون كم عدد من يتلذذون
بالمسلسلات الفصيحه كم عدد الذين يتلذذدون
بسماع مثلا اغاني ماجد
المهندسون مثلا قارئه الفنجان او يسمعون
او يقراون مثلا نزار درويش
هؤلاء لا حصل لهم وتجدينهم الثانويه فاذا
هذه لماذا لان الفكره العربيه اصبحت موحده
بالمناسبه هذه الدراسات او هذه الكتب
والروايات والاشعار والمسلسلات وهذا
التطور الحضاري والتداول الذي بين الناس
في في مثلا نقول في الوطن العربي يتحدث عن
الوطن العربي هو الذي جعلنا مثلا بالامس
يعني نجم فرحا بفوز المغرب وقتلها
السعوديه اذا هذه الفكره هي الفكره
ترابطيه مهمه جدا للتحقق
الفكره هنا بالعكس انا لا ارى انها مخيفه
بل
افضل مسابح يعني كم يقراون لدرويش عام
1990 كم بل ابعد من ذلك همم يعني
الفكره هنا فكره لنقل
التحضر او الاتجاه حتى للعلم والتعلم اصبح
كبيرا جدا انظري لحركه الترجمه بالوطن
العربي عام 1980 كم كانت الترجمه وكم
اصبحت الان الان نحن نتحدث عن مجلات
اصبحت تترجم يعني يعني ترجمه الان مثلا في
الواقع العربي كم عدد مثلا القنوات
الموجوده مثلا في اليوتيوب والتي تتحدث
مثلا سواء كان عن الشعر العربي
اللغات الرئيسيه يا دام احنا مش لازم ننسى
انه في 440 مليون بني ادم حول العالم عرب
يتائ- الناطقين بالعربيه بس على كل حال
انا لانه بديش الوقت يدعمنا والحديث معك
الحقيقه لا يوم العنجد همم بس طمنتني وانا
هلا صرت مطمنه بانه حتى لو ليلى بنتي ما
تعلمت عربي او ما حكت عربي اا في غيرها
ملايين راح مو هاي اللغه الجميله الفصيحه
انا ساقول هذه الفكره لاي طفل او لاي مثلا
اب او ام عنده مشكله معه اطفالي
علموهم ان يتحدثوا عن التفاصيل يعني مثلا
اذا قال مثلا رايت شجره قل ما معنى رايت
وما معنى العين لماذا هي بالعين ليست
بالاذن ولماذا مثلا قلنا »
[موسيقى]
اهم ههه والله بشكرك جزيلا الشكر على هذا
الحديث الجميل يعني استاذ طارق واكيد يعني
راح يكون لنا لقاءات اخرى متعلقه باللغه
يمكن نختار موضوعات شويه اكثر تخصصا من
موضوع هذه الحلقه شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
طارق القرني كان معنا من الرياض شكرا لك
قبل ما اترككم اعزائي يسمحوا لي اشاركم
بعض المعلومات المثيره للاهتمام عن لغات
العالم لبعض منها كمان اولا نصف سكان
العالم يعني اربعه مليارات انسان بيتكلموا
23 لغه فقط من اكثر من سبعه الاف لغه في
العالم كما انه نصف سكان العالم ثنائي او
مزدوجي اللغه يعني همم بيتكلموا لغتين
بطلاقه
اقدم لغه مكتوبه موثقه في التاريخ هي
اللغه السومريه وبعود تاريخها لا 3500 قبل
الميلاد وفي المركز الثاني بيجي بعدها
اللغه المصريه القديمه اللي بيعوت تاريخها
ل 3000 1300 قبل الميلاد ثلاثه اصغر
ابجديه في العالم تحتوي على 11 حرف فقط
وهي لغه البابوان وهي واحده من بين 800
لغه موجوده
اربعه هناك لغه في الكاميرون اللي بينطق
فيها كان عددهم ثمانيه اشخاص عام 86
وبعدين صاروا ثلاثه في عام 2005
ويمكن ما بعرف اذا ضل واحد منهم على الاقل
الان
5 مافي لغه رسميه رئيسيه في الولايات
المتحده
الانجليزي
اكبر عدد من البشر على وجه الارض
هي لا مش الانجليزيه
لانه واحد فاصل ثلاثه مليارات انسان
بيتكلموها وهي على فكره ليس لديها ابجديه
بل الهرموز
سبعه كلمه الابجديه نفسها
بالانجليزيه اكثر من
الناطقين بهذه اللغه في بريطانيا نفسها 90
مليون شخص في نيجيريا بيحكوا انجليزي
بينما 60 مليون في بريطانيا
اصل اللغه الانجليزيه
اكثر من 12 مليون و300 الف كلمه
في ختام حلقتنا ما بعرف اذا وافقت في
محاوله الاجابه على سؤال ليلى المشاكسه
ويمكن ما راح انجح في اقناعها بايجابتي او
مش راح انجح في تغيير رايها ولكن على
الاقل بعد البحث وبعد اعداد هذه الحلقه
انا اكثر اطمئنان على لغتنا العربيه
الجميله وبينها ستبقى ما بقينا
فكما قال الشاعر يحيى الحمادي بيني وذكراك
ارثون لم يزل عبقه
يقطع الازله من مهبط الضاض من لاميه لمست
لام الكلام الى ان قدرت عسل هذا كلام
منطقي على العربيه وانا راويه العالمي
اشكركم ودمتم دائما بامان باذن الله
[موسيقى]